[Music]
i called my mother yesterday as i do
almost every day
returning her phone call several phone
calls and she um was upset with me she
said
i opened the google and there i was i
said what do you mean she's like i was
right on the aol i i a story about the
two of us together about me and my
cancer what is going on
and i had forgotten to tell her that i
did an interview a couple weeks ago for
this cancer charity it's it's a support
group called survivor net and this
sounds like humble brother you are such
a wonderful i know but i'm telling you
how it happened and i did this thing for
kappa kai zoo shout out
it was a camp for kids that burned down
in the fires in california somebody
reached out about this interview and i
did it to help you know bring more
awareness to charity whatever i forgot
to tell my mother that it was all about
the interview was about how mom had
cancer which she did 15 years ago and
what it was like for us you know and you
described her as having a really good
attitude during yeah process and being
perky and i saw her yesterday too and
she was like she told me the whole story
too she's like i realized that he was
talking about me and he described me as
perky i said well
she maybe you weren't perky but
it's still nice that he did he mentioned
you and he did this nice thing for
charity she was like i know it is but i
wasn't perky i don't know why she was so
hung up to that she was perky i don't
remember her being really anyway
speaking of perky oh yeah okay let's
perk up the show life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your often perky host justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
uh with me as always is my maybe less
perk you're definitely less perfect yeah
i i think you might you've ever been
described as per no i think you might i
sound like you're no
no
i think
you might be offended just played dev's
outfit you might be offended to be
called perky if
you were going through
chemo and
you were going through a really hard
time and someone from the outside said
oh you seem perky yes but it might be
like come on i know but in the context i
would also i would i would weigh it in
the context which was i'm going through
this really difficult thing this these
procedures that you know she was bald i
mean i'm that was i remember that being
really hard for her i will say she
handled it very well exactly that's
that's the context but turkey but the
word perky maybe that's a little
condescending it's a little uh cutesy
cutesy and all and also
for the record you weren't there i know
and not because you're a bad son but
because you were working yeah i was
there because i'm a good son
uh and wasn't working and she wasn't she
was definitely i
less perky than her normal self she was
normally she's a very perky person well
you know what i also a person as we just
as discussed it's also one of those
stories where like well those interviews
where
if you choose the wrong word it's
forever there it's like you're talking
to somebody on the phone i'm s i have a
t this is just to defend myself as we
just learned i have a terrible memory as
you're constantly reminding me of i i
what was the thing i know i didn't
remember oh we were talking about how we
had a radio show when we were kids and i
didn't remember the name of it i have a
terrible memory and so
my memory is often
um
i guess way um
it's it's a little bit
it's malleable
more so than other people's memories and
it's a really flattering way to describe
bad memory and i have um i think it was
it was really influenced by this video
that i recently saw of
her
going during that time in this hotel
room they put me up at this you know
that hotel and she was so excited she
was like on cloud nine to be in this
fancy hotel room and so maybe that's
what i'm remembering definitely and also
again you weren't there you weren't
present yeah or no i know i'm not a
lion's share of this experience so the
lion's share
so um
so i think you just got snippets you got
phone calls and
yeah whatever and yeah speaking of that
was hard speaking of cancer and speaking
of perky but also like wait sorry to
interrupt uh i also hate that i it's i
sounded like i was the victim like this
was difficult for us it was her that was
going through it but that's what
survivor net does i think survivor net
is about it's a support system for
everybody who is dealing with cancer not
just the patients but the families of
the patients anyway it's a really good
thing if you want to check out survivor
net
and sorry mother for uh not telling you
that you were in people magazine and
sorry for continuing to publicly shame
you yeah it must have been weird to open
because she also i also said to her i'm
sure her algorithm the google algorithm
goes right i don't think it was like
headline news so
or she googles herself every day
yeah maybe i just think she googles me
enough that you know she was also like
and right next to that was a story about
about drew you know and so i think she's
always looking for stuff
that's a terrible impression yeah i know
that doesn't sound you make her sound
like a baddie old lady it sounded more
like true right that's true yeah that's
true
um sorry you were about to uh introduce
the guest yeah because it's a show yeah
where we have a really impressive guest
um but if you want to talk more that's
uh i know we can cut that out no no no
no no this is good stuff shut up okay so
speaking of perky oh that's right
katie's gonna be uh she's gonna be she's
not gonna listen i bet she will oh
really she's very supportive no i'm
nervous
i you should be sh she's one of our most
impressive if not our most impressive
easy yeah we don't get a lot she's no
offense to our other like for short
guests that we've had but uh we don't
get a lot of guests like this
she is uh she's special and she's uh
one of the most impressive figures
public figures and we have her on the
show why am i still talking her name is
katie couric yes you all know her she
doesn't really need an introduction well
she got a really long rambly one well
that's not technically that's not an
introduction of her that's just
supposed to be i know
okay
so but people know her primarily from
america just being you know like yeah if
you're lost in america you're living in
this country or abroad really oh yeah
everyone you know
she's one of our um foremost news people
journalists
uh she um was the host among other
things she's done she was the host of
the cbs evening news uh the first woman
to host the nightly news uh
shattering that ceiling that's right and
i i remember one point in my life she
was didn't she also do the morning [ __ ]
yeah today's show uh
good morning america today show today's
show she's really done it all she's done
it all so she and then she had like a
daytime show she was yeah there was at
any time of the day you could see katie
couric and you could um and she was
always uh so poised and present and
obviously very bright um i guess that
that all goes without saying maybe
that's actually condescending to say
well speaking of condescending i think
when she was younger in her career
earlier in her career she had this
label put on her
of america's sweetheart and speaking of
perky people described her as perky and
cute and
and um
which obviously in retrospect is quite
sexist it is that she was this
incredibly impressive journalist who was
being reduced to
cute and perky and america's sweetheart
and she was like she turned out to be
like our walter cronkite yeah our peter
jennings dan rather i mean she she's
right up there yeah she is uh a true
authority figure when it comes to
objective news delivery i mean when it
comes to journalism yeah you're right
she is in in those
hallowed halls of the greats the upper
echelon
but people with gr gravitas and
authority yes it just so happened to be
in this
cute
uh
package can i not even say that i don't
know i don't know she's very she's
attractive okay i mean physically so so
is daniel rather no one talked about his
face you're right it's not fair you're
right peter jennings was too bad yeah
very happy really handsome we can say we
and we do talk about how handsome he was
so can we hear from her can i hear from
her i would love you to i would like to
too again because that's how i mean i
like listening to you talk too
okay here we go and everyone you're
about to listen to um i'll say it our
most impressive guest
and one of the most impressive uh public
figures of the last quarter century
the
intimidable
intimidable admittable admittable uh
indomitable indomitable intubatable she
has an indomitable spirit in
into oh well the opposite of me katie
couric
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again should boom and double
we'll meet again
[Music]
is this kind of like a break for you to
do this not not that i'm saying
i'm so grateful that you're taking the
time but as as such an accomplished
interviewer is it kind of nice to
be on the other side of it and
let other people struggle with questions
it depends
it depends on who's asking the questions
and
i guess yeah you know the chemistry i
have with them and sort of what they're
interested in talking about but
um you know i think there's so much
content out there justin now that right
that uh
you know and i'm sort of not in the
white hot spotlight like i used to be so
i can get away with saying a lot more
than i used to uh when i was like
anchoring the cbs evening news or even
doing the today show where is that a
relief for you is that a nice yeah
i think it's liberating honestly i mean
i think i'm i'm definitely more vocal
than i would be if i were in mainstream
media right now um
and i still try to not be
hyper partisan but i i am able to speak
my mind and
not have all these pr people around me
i've noticed that i i've noticed that as
a follower as an avid follower of your
instagram account you you continue to
report um
objectively but you i i it's it's hard
to mistake a
yeah a slight bias uh in terms of well i
think you know honestly it i think
it's hard not to be biased today i think
if if you have to if you're honest with
yourself if you're honest with the kind
of things that have been going on
the kinds of
antics that have been i think
routinely performed by the trump
administration and
the undermining of our democratic
institutions whether it's the press
whether it's the law
whether it's the electoral process and i
think it's
it's it's really hard to sit back and
be that kind of on one hand on the other
hand or you know
this and then you know giving that a
different perspective when someone is
behaving in a way that's so
unconscionable i i
just finished i'm wrapping up my memoirs
and i i interviewed david duke uh many
years ago who is you know a white
supremacist uh
a really
disgusting yeah disgusting guy and
i i remember i had just started on the
today show and i gave him holy hell i
i quoted back at him in a very tim
russert s way and for the listeners tim
russell was the
esteemed uh host or you know uh
moderator of meet the press for many
years and i think he's honestly never
been replaced on any
sunday public affairs show but i i just
gave it to david duke and my dad called
me and said bravo my dad was a print
journalist and he said
you know that was edward r murrow worthy
and sometimes i think
you know while journalists are supposed
to be objective and and i do think
they've crossed the line and become
almost too outwardly opinionated rolling
their eyes or laughing or shaking their
heads incessantly
um i do think that various things that
the trump administration and the
president himself
have done over the last four years
you know they need to be called out and
they're completely unacceptable so you
know yeah in order but in order to as
your dad said give it to david duke um
and go after somebody like that don't
you
don't you need to
um
coax them
in don't you need to make them somehow
comfortable enough to
uh
to to almost trap them into saying
certain things um not i think it depends
i think every interview honestly
is different and you take a different
tact with everybody
you're
you're you know talking to i think in
his case
he was running for president or maybe
he's running for senate louisiana
you know
did he win ever was he a [ __ ] did he win
a congressional heat
i i i have to look it up i don't know
i don't i think he might have been a
congressman for a short
time
you know this is the wonders of google
yeah and i'm gonna look that up oh [ __ ]
i would but my ipad just ran out of
juice so now now your
your google algorithm is gonna get
confused they're gonna wonder if you're
looking them up because you're a fan or
hopefully not
i think yeah see if he was a member of
congress he might have been a one-term
congressman but
i don't remember i know he ran for a
bunch of different things and had a
short-lived uh run for the presidency um
but but how do you go into that
interview and and remain at least
outwardly as objective as possible how
how are is there a performance uh
element that that comes into play i
think for that interview i i actually
just quoted quoted some of his heinous
comments back to him like jews belong in
the dustbin of
society or something just and and some
very racist anti-asian remark i think he
said
you know buy our rice we know by you
know we know buy your you know buy our
cars we know buy your rice or something
and i said doesn't that sound
dangerously like no ticky no laundry and
you know i think i i was just very well
prepared and um
you know
i think that
that his rec his
his record of saying
uh really uh inappropriate
obnoxious and racist anti-semitic things
was so
uh clear that i didn't have to trip him
into anything i just used his words to
kind of ask him about his position so
but you know with sarah palin it was
different because
as madeleine albright told me at the
time she was a blank slate and nobody
really knew
her views of the world or how she would
govern or her political philosophy
and and they've never they had never
heard her really articulate it except
for
at the republican national convention so
i didn't trap her but what i i did give
her um room and air time to kind of
to to elaborate on
policy positions and you know i think
what america discovered and i painfully
observed is she just couldn't do it you
know
she wasn't ready for prime time and plus
she had that added
added handicap of having this very
strange cadence and way of talking yes
that was very marge gunderson you know
in fargo there was something kind of
condescending about her tone and her
delivery i remember i even when she when
you did the double interview with mccain
and palin he um
that to me was almost
more impressive because you were
navigating both of them in such a deft
way and he was kind of trying to
[Music]
he he was trying to support her support
her
and ex
explain what she was
going for i think she had said something
about um
uh assad if we had were we to attack
syria we would want you know we would
let them know or something like that and
mckinsey she said something dumb on you
know she was in a rope line and i can't
remember but it was
it was kind of contrary to u.s policy
and yes it was just kind of a blunder
and you know i i chalked that up to the
fact that she was just painfully
inexperienced in a a on a national stage
but but it was remarkable that she
wasn't able to and i find this often
with politicians with many people uh
that they can't admit that they made a
mistake it's very difficult to even now
republican democrat it's it seems very
difficult for um
a politician to and and when they do on
the rare occasion they do i find it's so
admirable i'm
trying to remember exactly what it was
but mccain and palin were both accusing
that blunder uh they were they were both
accusing gotcha politics of being
responsible for that blunder right you
know it's gotcha politics how do you
and and you were so good at you were so
measured and
and um
and it you wouldn't let up on them how
do you ride that line between
anger potentially angering somebody and
and staying on course with a line of
questioning like that specifically in
that case how do you how do you hang in
there i think you know a lot of it is
tone
i think you you try to be persistent and
um
you know i think i i think it takes
actually a fair amount of emotional
intelligence and ability to read the
room to figure out how far you can push
without it actually just seeming rude
so it's it's always that kind of balance
you know and also i always had this kind
of slight
smile on my face in a pleasant way
so that i think that i never
came across as an attack dog in fact
sometimes i
i got in the habit of smiling too much
when i was doing a serious thing and
instead of being sort of totally without
an expression because i also i think i
used to smile to kind of encourage
people you know that i was i was i was
hearing them i was engaged i was
listening i was you know wanted them to
continue
so um i don't know i think it's just you
just have to kind of feel it out but
katie was that deliberate or was that
just how you were socially is that just
uh did that just come naturally
something like that
i don't know i don't know i remember
early on
uh you know i used to nod
and and and i i learned very early on
from someone you know you cannot nod and
it's funny because once in a while i see
people on television or on online
nodding oh i do it all the time it is it
is not cool i mean you can do it with
some people but when you're doing it
with a politician it or somebody in a
position of authority it gives viewers
the impression that you agree with them
so you can't be like
oh
so you cannot you cannot nod oh
interesting because early on i found
myself listening back to some of these
interviews i i realized i had some
really obnoxious habits and
one of them was was constantly
affirming what the person was saying
i'm still doing it um well that's okay i
think in podcasting actually
i think that's actually that's
surprisingly encouraged you know i don't
know if you listen to michael barbaro on
the daily but he he goes
mm-hmm yeah and and i think there's
something for the listener
that reminds people especially if it's a
long
complicated answer that kind of reminds
people that there's somebody on the
other side of the microphone so i don't
i don't think it's necessarily a really
a bad thing especially
in the in this medium what have you what
have you learned about interviewing do
you feel like you've gotten better i
hope
people listening might think otherwise
but yeah you know i think i've i've
gotten more patient um talking to
somebody like you
is a little different because you are
this is what you do you're one of the
best at doing this so it's kind of like
it's a bit like playing
you know like playing one-on-one with
michael jordan or something i i'm i'm
far more intimidated i think than i
normally would be i i'm trying to play
it very cool
well
you know well first of all i don't know
i don't i i hope you're not intimidated
because
you know i i've been doing this a long
time and if i weren't good at it there'd
be something really wrong with me
because i mean the 10 000 hours of
experience that malcolm gladwell talks
about i think i've had probably a
hundred thousand hours or more uh so i
should be pretty good at it but you know
i i think it's just really being
interested in people and and listening
and
i think doing your homework's important
because
i think um
you know i remember feeling so insulted
uh at times during my career when
i was doing something maybe i was in an
event i was doing something it was so
clear that the person
you know had no idea and had had hadn't
given it a moment's thought and
well i think it was it was more that
they just asked really dumb questions
and it becomes a waste of time yeah it
was sort of insulting honestly you know
what what was something that you learned
early on that maybe you
came to realize um was getting in the
way of of the interview being as good as
it could be something that you had to
kind of adjust in your behavior
yeah on live television you know it's
it's really hard i mean even with a
podcast you know if you really screw it
up you can edit it out right or you can
oh so far
but you know on live television that
kind of raises the stakes
so much and i can't imagine it took me a
a a long time to a feel comfortable on
live television because everything you
do everything you say every facial
expression you you give is kind of under
a microscope and
i think for
i had to get comfortable enough to
um
you know not rely on a list of questions
and to really listen to know the subject
matter well enough that i could able to
translate it to the general public but
not so well that i was talking at a
certain level that nobody could
understand right that it wasn't too
granular in the weeds but i think i
learned early on how important how
critically important is
to
well there are a few things make make
the person feel make the person
comfortable unless
you know it's a someone who's you know i
didn't want to make david do comfortable
if you're holding someone's feet to the
fire
but but there are certain situations
where someone is is bearing his or her
soul and you want them to feel
heard and cared for
and and in a way protected if under
certain circumstances as i said every
situation is different but then i think
you just really want to be a great
listener
and
and i think you want to listen so well
and know the subject matter so well or
know kind of what you're trying to
solicit from that person that you can
throw away your notes and pick up on a
point and then say well what do you mean
by that or
um well that's so interesting in fact i
was going to ask you that later but
let's talk about it now you know that
right right you're able to be more
present um and more spontaneous yeah huh
so in the case of not to labor the sarah
palin interview but but um
just as a touchstone something like that
was was the
do you go in with an agenda do you go in
or or in that case was it i just want
her to expand on
some of the little limited things she's
already said and uh some some of her
i mean i think
i mean i think i i didn't go in with an
agenda per se but
my goal was
was
to really i mean in some ways
hold her feet to the fire to in some
ways make sure that she understood
public policy that makes to make sure
that
you know if you'll remember john mccain
at the time was going to be the oldest
president he had had melanoma four times
um she would be as we know a heartbeat
away from the presidency and
and i wanted to make sure that you know
that she knew what she was talking about
and
she had performed sort of
she was sort of skimming the trees with
charlie gibson uh when he did an
interview with her and so i just i
really we we just made it broad and as
madeleine albright said
she's a blank slate let her talk
and so
that's one thing that
that i really learned during
the sarah palin interview and i think i
knew it before but
i think with interviewing sometimes you
want to fill up the
the silence or the the empty spaces yes
because especially on live television
where like two seconds seems like an
eternity sure this was tape but even so
i didn't i didn't rescue her you know i
didn't come in i just listened
what publications do you read you don't
fill them you don't offer any that's
what i would have done i would have said
you know for example like such and such
i would have given her options yeah
but there was and that was just a very
very kind of i think awful that question
out of my ass that was just to kind of
get b-roll and that's why oh my god
yeah
other questions yeah it almost looked
like katie correct me if i'm wrong that
you
did she have a handler off camera that
was like let's move on from that i i got
the sense that there were people around
her who were like they recognized that
she was drowning a bit are there people
like that who were trying to publicist
and stuff trying to get you off yeah i
think i think the time
uh you know to get a walking and talking
shot
there wasn't anyone within her line of
vision because
you know you have to kind of clear the
area it's more when you're sitting there
that you have somebody
who may
you know say wait a second okay time's
up i have that with gal gadot who i
really liked and i was talking to her
about being in the israeli army which is
so insane and so
you know and i always want to give
actors
you know an opportunity to show that
they're smart you know
and well you know and or you know to
talk about well-rounded if they want to
talk about it yeah and and her publicist
was like just
really really on me to to wrap it up and
and you know and i don't know whether
you know maybe it was a good cop bad pop
thing but
i really like gal gadot and i was really
interested just fascinating background
and uh
you know but who knows they might
want palestinians who knows yeah
why i think you're probably no i'm
kidding i was gonna say or publish this
i was like what
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
when you were a kid katie do you
remember your earliest do you remember
falling in love with journalism do you
remember having a moment where you
thought that's what i want to do did you
have that
moment in childhood i mean i always like
to write you know i remember
i had a poem in my first grade my
elementary school like journal
and it was snow is fun yes you are right
it gives you quite an appetite but the
problem was i had plagiarized it from my
book by petey eastman called snow
and and it was one of those things i was
six i didn't quite probably understand
what plagiarism was yeah and i had just
like written it and then it got
published i remember feeling it
even at a young age completely mortified
written and and just embarrassed and
were you discovered did peter eastman i
i don't know pete eastman did not call
jamestown elementary and complain and it
wasn't an expose in the washington post
or anything but i just remember kind of
thinking oh wait that that really wasn't
my problem i don't remember even talking
to my mom and dad about it but i think
it's because i was six and it was like
not a big deal but oh i'm sorry i think
about i think about feeling so ashamed
that i did that
so ashamed oh god needless to say i
never plagiarized again so maybe that
was a good lesson early on to not take
credit for someone else's work but i
just loved words i loved language my dad
was a print journalist for the atlanta
constitution in the united united press
my father was just this incredible
renaissance man
sounds a little like your dad justin my
dad was uh you know loved history could
kind of talk fluently about anything i
just i i just
worshipped him and
as you know as i wrote i have a memoir
coming out and i wrote that i think it
was my dad that that made me fall in
love with words and he used to ask us to
come to the dinner table with a new
vocabulary word i remember coming with
like incongruous was our incongruity was
one of my words and um
and and i just i i like i've always been
sort of creative and i just fostered i
just love yeah and i just and my mom was
quite creative my mom
was very clever
and a really good artist and you know in
a different era i think she would have
been a working woman she would have she
did layout for for coronet which i think
was a
a branch or a precursor to esquire in
chicago and she was a cartographer for
rand mcnally and wow but then when she
got married you know she stopped working
because
you know i mean
i i'm i'm sort of a generation ahead of
you but most parents of people my age
most mothers
didn't work
well yeah yeah yeah
did you have a lot of maps around the
house a lot of uh framed maps no
no no but my not painted and i have a
couple of her paintings and
they were just you know i just i've been
going through a lot of letters i'm a
pack rat and i've been going through
things for my book to
find photographs and all that for the
insert and i'm just amazed i mean this
it made me sort of sad because people
just don't write letters anymore and i
have my mom
and to a lesser extent my dad but my mom
wrote me
so many letters when i was in college
and i i saw this other letter that right
before i i came to you where my sister
emily wrote to me she was 10 years older
she she died of pancreatic cancer when
she was 54 but she must have been at
smith college that's where both my
sisters went to school and and uh
she said i can't believe it you're nine
years old
and and it was just it's such a treasure
obviously because i lost my sister but
just to have that physical
thing in an envelope to see her
handwriting and to see my mom's kind of
cool block print because she was kind of
you know
kind of graphically inclined so even the
way she wrote her letters and in her
letters
yeah but it's just you know the letter
writing is such a lost art and there's
something for me
that is just so unbelievably precious
to have these things in a box and when
when my husband jay died you know i
asked
uh at his funeral what my sister emily
read the eulogy i'd written because it
was just too hard for me to do that but
i asked everyone
there if they could to write a letter to
my daughters about their father
and so ellie was only
six when jay died and carrie had just
turned two and so i have these letters
from
child boyhood friends of jays from
friends of his
in high school at wnl where he played
lacrosse i have letters from he was in
the navy
from people i have a letter from a woman
who's now the mayor of seattle jenny
durkin who worked at my with my husband
at williamson conley a law firm in
washington who wrote to the girls that
the first after our first date that jay
walked into her office at the firm and
said i i just met the girl i'm gonna
marry and it was so cute and all these
letters are just
so moving and you know i i've often said
to people if you lose
if you lose someone you love
and in fact i have a friend who just
lost her husband she has a five-year-old
son
that
that those are you know
i think it makes them sad to read them
but someday they're going to be so
grateful that they have these
like your daughters i mean do they how
often do they
read those do they ever take those out i
i i pulled them out a few times i think
once i that terry does and carrie's very
interested in sort of our family history
and
uh on my my dad's side we have a lot of
uh you know southerners and
people who are in the confederacy and
kerry is very
very into history and
is appalled appalled by our civil war
provenance and um why
well because no of course you know yeah
and and jay
my husband and their dad
back in the 90s did used to be a civil
war reenactor
for the confederacy he was obsessed with
he was obsessed i would say
somewhat with the civil war but also he
was kind of obsessed with
military
uh militaria and wow his dad fought in
world war ii and
so i think it's been very confounding
for carrie especially who's extremely
woke
uh and i say that in a good way and um
and uh yes and but but it's it's been
hard for her to
square jay's passion for the civil war
with the kind of reckoning that we've
seen in recent years about confederate
iconography and
kind of how the civil war heretofore has
been presented to us so
it's been really interesting uh i bet
and and was j so jay he would actually
so he would dress up and they would why
do did you ever go along with him to any
of those
i know that i i know that we walked
around one that he wasn't participating
in but i used to tease him and say if
you think i'm gonna you know uh walk
around in a hoops spurt in a snood
i just like to say
dudes are great one of those nettie
things that yeah fun or your ponytail or
whatever i said you know you've got
another thing coming and he'd always say
hey it's much better than drinking
gambling and chasing women
i say yeah you're right and you know he
loved he loved horses he was quite a
talented equestrian and i think he was
also a really um
he was such a reverse snob that
i think he liked the cross section of
people who were who were drawn to
this this kind of activity you know so
he would have dentists and lawyers and
plumbers and
all kinds of different people that
that i think also with two girls and a
pretty strong you know strong-willed
wife i think he loved the male bonding
there yeah and they'd sleep in tents and
you know they came out of these chairs
and plates and it's so crazy it is funny
that you would be with somebody like
that and obviously
be so because you don't yeah i mean but
it's it's also nice that you
allow it's funny i was going to ask you
because you seem like you have such a
great relationship now with your husband
i was going to ask are there things that
you just don't get that he's into
um that you're talking about
golf
oh my god he's right now he's like funny
pig and [ __ ] he is in augusta playing oh
and oh my god he was like a kid on
christmas morning last night i talked to
him and he was like i'm leaving it i got
to get up at 5 30. i'm so excited i got
my covet test i'm negative and i'm real
and it's just so and you know after a
while and
you know i think you should support
someone's passion even if you don't
share it right because if something
gives
so and
and i i mean i i was supportive of jay i
mean i used to roll my eyes and be like
you're insane and what are you doing and
but
you know in retrospect i think what i
realized is
you know isn't it great when somebody
gets so much pleasure from something and
then you're like i am so glad plus
i like being independent i like doing my
own thing and i don't want to be
you know um you know stuck to my partner
24 7. so i'm tall for them i'm all for
people to have different interests and
very fully supportive and you've got a
couple of john free days now you can do
your own yeah well you know actually
i've been out in long on long island on
long island yes a lot of the up for a
lot of the pandemic he's been in the
city and we kind of go back and forth
but
but writing my book was a very intense
exercise and i was
you know really kind of
had to have my nose to the grindstone so
he runs our company and we work together
which has also been really well you did
the cooking show
well right now he's the ceo of a you
know we have 25 employees now oh wow
we're creating all kinds of different
content and a newsletter and a podcast
and digital shorts wow i'm developing
some scripted things and documentaries
so we're like a full-fledged media
company you're an enterprise well i know
john's also friends with michael j fox
and i just finished michael's book
loved god
i haven't read it yet but everyone loves
it john uh you know
john just loves
loves mike
i saw their interview they seemed like
they really got along
yeah and he and and i mean
i have always been such a such an
incredible admirer of michael j fox i
mean from from a long time ago i mean
he's been dealing with parkinson's for
decades now and something that you knew
was close to you yeah i know your dad
yeah my dad my dad had parkinson's but
you know my dad got parkinson's
when he was about in his early 80s and
lived to be 90 and we were so lucky but
but for someone like michael j fox to
get it at such an early age and he's
just been
i mean he is heroic and
about what was it about the book that
really resonated with you i'm just
curious
well you know it was the
the ability that this human being has to
overcome uh trials that i think would
fell any
normal person uh the
the resolve that he has the ability to
find um
gratitude and and maintain a sense of
optimism in the face of this
extraordinarily
uh
debilitating thing that i i especially
somebody who was so active you know who
was so the way he moved i mean people
don't always think about michael j fox
as like a great physical comedian but
he he really was i mean his um
some of the things he does there's a
shot and see the secret of my success
where he's and he talks about it in the
book where
i it's this tracking shot where he's
like a dancer i mean he moved uh
beautifully and yeah to lose that
ability and and the things that we just
take for granted and
his sense of um
continued sense of optimism is really
incredible it's he i mean and and and i
really admire you know he had that
terrible year in 2018
that's mostly what it's about what the
book is about and uh
where where he had some unrelated issues
i don't want to
uh you know from the parkinson's but you
know i i see him and tracy who's a doll
socially
and you know
i i think the fact that there's he's so
comfortable and tracy too
you know there's there's something that
you know your heart stops a little bit
when you see
when you see mike and and he's walking
and and you feel like he's struggling
and you you know it's that impulse like
you're worried and he does not want help
you know he does not want help but but
the fact that he is
i mean he's gotten to the point i think
it's because he's lived with this for so
long that he
he can go
out in public
and
clearly he's aware that he's struggling
but he it there's something about his um
i'm trying to think he just has this
this um presence and the self-awareness
that he just kind of forges ahead
and you don't get the sense that he's
embarrassed or ashamed or like feeling
like
this is so awkward i mean it's just he
has fully embraced who he is and some of
the
the challenges he faces in a way that
that that makes everyone else relax i
don't think i explained that very well
but no no that doesn't make sense and i
remember briefly i got to work with him
uh
on the last show he did which which he
he talks about in the book as being
something that
i think motivated him to stop backing
for a little while i think i don't i
don't think it was the best experience
it was called it was the michael j fox
show
um and i oh right that was after the
good wife right it was after the good
wife yeah it was kind of the last he was
and he i don't want to speak out a term
but he talks about this in the book and
it was a starring role and i think it
was too
[Music]
too much for him and i remember thinking
um
i i i got the sense that he never showed
frustration but but um
i remember thinking god this must be
infuriating because he
was such a master of timing you know
he's such a
brilliant comedian and actor and um
and and because of this physical
impairment he wasn't he just physically
wasn't able to deliver
uh wasn't able to employ the timing that
i know that
he was capable of you know um
it must be uh i i remember thinking
that that's something that would
knock me out i would be down for the
count um and i would never be able to to
express any gratitude or and
you know when you read about his his
continued gratitude and optimism and so
much of it seems to come from tracy and
his family
does he talk honestly about i mean
because i'm sure he gets very frustrated
i mean this is so funny we're having
this whole conversation for
mike and he's like you don't really know
me that well but
does he talk about the moments where he
feels so frustrated and or he's honest
about all that yeah yeah totally honest
about it and i i katie i actually
recommend i because i listened to the
book i bought the book um
but then i
ended up listening to most of it on
audio uh and he's and it's such a great
performance too so you get to because i
miss him as a performer so you get a
little bit of that too
and so
i mean i have it um i have it and it's
definitely on my my list of books to
read but um you're ready to be great to
hear life could be a dream sweetheart
hello
hello we'll
[Music]
you know part of part of the reason i've
been sort of hesitant to read
a lot of books like that is i'm afraid
that i'll plagiarize like i did
[Music]
that somehow it will kind of influence
the way i write no i'm serious so i
really stayed away
i didn't read michelle obama's book yet
because
i was like oh am i gonna try to sound
just like michelle obama and that's
gonna be so sad and pathetic and so
um now that i'm almost done and i'm just
putting the finishing touches on my book
now i feel like and i can read other
people's memoirs finally that makes
perfect sense um
and you also
how how do i was going to ask you
because you seem like somebody who was
constantly working that might be i might
be
misled about that but you seem like you
are
a are you a real is your work ethic as
as strong as i think it is
it's actually too strong it's like i'm
afraid
i'm afraid of slowing down and and i
mean i think this is
probably a fodder for really fine
therapists but i i i'm i've always been
kind of a workaholic i've always been
super productive and
i
i think it's it's sort of you know a
pathetic
a pathetic uh
kind of
i don't know pathetic effort uh
for relevance and
for for mattering and
um but i also am i'm still really
interested and curious about a lot of
things and i feel like
you know for a certain segment of the
population if i can help increase
understanding or expose people to
certain ideas
you know or you've been doing that with
your instagram yeah that's what well
i've actually kind of formed you know
and i really love i know it sounds so
silly but
i feel close to people who follow me i
feel like we've developed this community
i don't know if you feel like that on
your instagram too it's it's funny i
know i was gonna say i feel like though
we've never
spoken i
with you for example i do feel like i
kind of know you a little bit
yeah and but also like you you sometimes
comment and i'll comment back yeah yeah
but there's something um
leslie jordan don't you think you know
leslie jordan oh yeah he's he's he's a
doll isn't he
yes
oh i love funny
what does he say well what what how well
she is
[ __ ] how y'all doing he came to see me
this summer and it was so funny he
wasn't he was in east hampton
i think i must have seen him that's the
funny thing about instagram you know
yeah i think i might have seen a post
and i was like oh my god leslie jordan's
in east hampton come and have some sweet
tea
oh my god i'd be tickled too
and he came and he sat on my veranda
and we had some sweet tea and he's just
he's just the most darling and he just
is you know isn't it funny that the kind
of people who have emerged
during this pandemic and what what i've
been really blown away by in in the best
way possible is how creative and funny
and you know there were all these
gatekeepers for so long
on the creative community and when i say
the creative community i mean every
community and every person i don't mean
hollywood but
you know and
and and who got to have a shot was
dictated by you know people who may have
a particular
point of view or a particular life
experience or
whatever there's something very
democratic about this yeah and there's
it is so awesome to see people like
randy rainbow out there doing these
parodies um and you know i just
interviewed robin shaw who was this
darling comedian and she's just
hilarious and she
jen garner posted it first
and um it was about how her 2020 goals
had really just been you know gone to
[ __ ] and and she was laughing about him
because it was like socialize more make
more money lose weight and she kept
saying like oh i've gained 30 pounds
socialize more you know stop you know
don't drink as much and she's be around
more people yeah and and and spend more
time with my grandmother and then
it's in a a sad ironic twist she said
and my grandmother died and she's but
she's laughing at the absurdity
of all this and it's it's so she's so
captivating and
jen posted it yeah she's really funny
jen posted it
and it went crazy
and then i posted it or i i think i
did i posted or did i reach out to her i
think i must have posted it
i didn't want to like be too much of a
copycat because you don't want to be
like that person but i ended up doing an
instagram live with her
oh wow now she's going to do some
interviews for me oh my god my company
um because honestly look it's you know
nobody's understood this better than
donald j trump but you it's all about
disintermediation as they say like you
can go directly to consumers you don't
have to beg some executive
give you a shot you don't have to suck
up to them you don't have to laugh at
their dumb jokes
you must have done your share of all of
that i can only imagine i i don't think
i was as good at it as i should have
been and i think probably you know in
retrospect
not being political not a lot like
playing the game more i'm just a very
direct person i'm respectful but i'm
just not very good at like
oh you're so dreamy and smart and that
kind of thing that's just not not my jam
so was
katie was there anyone that that
surprised you in terms of their
personality that you were really thrown
by that maybe um
you know they behaved in a way that was
completely counter to what your
image of them had been
let's get back to that i'm panicking a
little bit because jarrett said we have
10 minutes i'm so sorry no that's that's
what i'm you're fine
um
i do want to talk about your your cancer
charity katie because i know that cancer
is a disease it's affected so many
people you've talked about your sister
and uh your husband where can people
donate uh if they're looking to get
involved how might they do that oh
you're so sweet justin that's so nice of
you well you know i i i really dealt
with the colons initially because jay
died of colon cancer at 42 and
you know it's the number two cancer
killer of men and women combined and
uh oh adriana my ipad's out of juice
yeah should we charge it for five
minutes anyway um adrian is my assistant
slash daughter
you didn't tell me you were relate i
asked if you were related she's not no
she's not i kind of adopted her but
anyway whoops um so i actually learned
about it through chadwick chadwick um
when you posted about chadwick boseman i
didn't know that's how your husband had
passed away
and i know you've done you've been such
an instrumental part um in terms of
getting awareness for colon cancer yeah
i did a colonoscopy on the today show i
got jimmy kimmel to do a colonoscopy
justin maybe you'll do one with me when
you get to be
50 or 45 actually 45 45 really yeah uh
they lowered the age of a strange
colonoscopy so all your listeners uh
please
you know tell people you love for the
fiverr over women
jay was only 42 i know he was and so he
but they're seeing more and more uh
cases among
uh you know younger people but anyway so
then i i realized that we needed to
support cancer scientists of all kinds
of cancer scientists so
uh i started stand up to cancer with
eight other crazy women like me because
we want we were frustrated we wanted to
see more collaboration and less
competition
and so we've raised i think over 600
million dollars to support science and
they do they work in dream teams where
they collaborate and so they share
their research and their tissue samples
and
their experiences at first they were so
proprietary they didn't want to do that
but then i think it was incredibly
invigorating to have this kind of
teamwork model yeah and uh so it's been
great
so people can go the website they can
make a donation if it's really it's a
very much research-based organization
because
you know i feel like gosh we can come up
with a copic vaccine and
in less than a year we should be able to
come up with better
you know diagnostic tools and treatment
for for all kinds of cancer which you
know a person dies of cancer every
minute in this country
god in heaven it'd be great to also
divert some of those funds from you know
cosmetic surgeries and more superficial
uh medical
advancements uh
to to something you know more don't tell
that don't tell the women on park avenue
that no no i won't they don't listen
anyway um okay stand up to cancer these
are
katie i'm sorry to diminish uh
these other things i wanted to talk
about that included but um
uh this is a very short really quick
like lightning round okay you can do it
we can do it we'll be five minutes late
for andrew he won't care okay what is
your most commonly used emoji katie
the one with the big eyes that um or the
eye roll but usually the surprise and i
like the little glasses guy too yes
nerdy i love it
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
um
uh
baseball baseball you have a team at the
mets yankees i used to like the
washington senators that they don't
exist anymore that's right they're okay
the national that's more or less i i
guess the yankees i'm a new yorker at
this point okay if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it what would it be you go to
snack food barbecue potato chips
delicious uh um what's your go-to
karaoke song
crazy by patsy klein oh great song okay
uh who was your first celebrity crush
that you can remember
my first celebrity crush
uh davey jones of the monkeys the
monkeys sure um
adorable uh if you had to get a tattoo
of what would you get and wear on your
body i would get it on my uh uh right
above my ass and it would be i think it
would be because i wouldn't want people
to see it i'm not a tattoo person but i
don't get jpm because my late husband
was john paul monahan my current husband
is john paul mullmer
and my dad was john martin so i feel
like those initials play a really
important role in my life oh great
answer great uh what is your favorite
fruit
uh my favorite fruit uh i i'd say
cantaloupe in the summer with really
good prosciutto oh wow
i love peaches too
yeah nice ripe george
uh who would you want to play you in
your biopic
sally field maybe oh perfect yes my god
uh what's your favorite simpsons
character
uh
i'm gonna have to say marge
yeah okay uh dogs are cats
i i like both i like both i can't
yeah beetles beetles are the stones i
gotta go with the beetles i don't know
no there's no shame in that i i would
too seinfeld or friends if they're both
on too much yes
correct uh ketchup or mustard on a hot
dog anything does it depend on what it
goes
on on a hot dog i'd have to say mustard
oh okay uh and the one adjective finally
the one adjective you'd want people to
use to describe you after you've left
the earth what would be your
your hope not perky
um
not america's sweetheart no
no
generous
well i i thank you for being generous
with your time and uh with so much way i
just gave you justin thank you
that's what i would say about you she's
very generous with segways
i mean generosity of spirit and
hopefully other ways but you know i
think it's a generous person i think
that means a lot right giving and caring
i think i think so selfless and uh
yeah i can't thank you enough for really
katie
ann and i've been really looking forward
to this justin so likewise we will meet
again maybe one day in person and i
would like oh yeah remember that are you
in l.a
uh i'm in connecticut actually i can't
tell
um
yeah i'm in um
anyway listen i gotta go because i have
to talk to andrew ross sorkin about the
economy right now so i've got to go
right
yeah uh you'd want to talk about fruit
more
um i'll ask him his favorite fruit
please too katie thank you i i'm such an
admirer of yours i i'm
truly grateful that you did this well
thank you thanks justin have a wonderful
holiday
big kiss thanks back
so that happened
that's my that's your uh dan rather
yeah uh oh would you rather uh i do
peter would you rather peter jennings
than dan would you dan rather dan dan uh
peter jennings was always
my favorite growing up
my two he just you know why i think you
don't both have like peter jennings kids
you know why i think i just realized
this canadian
oh oh maybe yeah you both have to think
of canadians are more impressive than
americans in general uh here's why i
think it may be because he looked a lot
like christopher reeve he did yeah and
we i think so wow you if you had given
me a thousand guests oh really i
wouldn't have come up with that oh
didn't he look a lot like yeah now that
you say it yeah and we of course to us
christopher reeve was the ultimate
authority yeah he was i
didn't get any more he was superman you
know i just had a theory right about why
oh share it well um because we watched
jeopardy a lot growing up and that was
on abc
at seven yeah and peter jennings was on
abc that came on just before right at 6
30. yes yeah
so maybe there was we wanted some
consistency we we had we wanted to get
that channel on anyway like you're
saying why didn't we watch ted koppel or
dan rather right who's the other one the
uh uh ted koppel who was like tom brokaw
tom walcott broco's nbc dan rather was
cbs and trump broke i like tom brokaw
too
i i liked that he that tom brokaw had uh
he had a slight speech impediment and he
was still one of the most distinguished
journalists is that good it's good but i
i don't know
but peter jennings was there was just
something he was my guy but then along
comes here we are uh lauding
the me the men of this
industry industry was just a side note i
also really like katie correct but yeah
katie kerr comes along and it's she has
the same kind of authority same gravitas
that's pretty amazing to go from
being described as cute and perky and
american sweetheart you know being on
the you know mount rushmore with these
distinguished figures
talk about uh a trailblazer
yeah and a transformation too or
changing perceptions because
you know
it's
that is a very difficult thing in and of
itself to do to change the way the
public thinks when you are that
when the public is galvanized that
strong opinion opinion of you
um and then to have altered it so
radically and
god is she's impressive for so many
reasons i mean what she went through um
the the the trauma the tragedy that
she's she's i had forgotten yeah
about her sister i know and her first
husband 42 i know i know she had i it
was reminded of it when she posted about
chadwick boseman and
um she just seems like she has
she's weathered so many she has a real
strength yes yes that's it you know
people she you might even describe her
as
badass
um yeah i mean i i think that's a badass
quality uh that kind of strength to
overcome yeah something like that i
i just i'm i'm glad i haven't had to um
try that yet i i can't imagine having to
try it but she she did it uh several
times over
uh the conversation was i would say less
of a conversation than a typical episode
and more
an interview
and i think
in part that's because
that's the format
she excels at i think so
i think so and and in her defense that's
what
that's how this was all set up i mean
i think if i think podcasting because
it's relatively new i think it's it's
it's best when it's a flowing
conversation when it is just kind of
like a um a back and forth but
i think she comes from
and i'm not saying that this made for a
bad podcast i think
i also am so deferential to her that i i
was happy to let her kind of
yeah you cut her you kept trying to pop
in at first to make it more
conversational and you're like
and she would
and this this is gonna sound uh
insulting but i don't mean it this way
she would kind of plow past you
and keep and but like
in an intelligent way and of course and
finish her train of thought yeah but you
kept trying to poke in there
i get picturing you like a little like
uh like a meerkat yeah what are those
things that pop uh moles or meerkats do
that underground
yeah
i pictured you as a mole being like but
a whack-a-mole yeah and she um and she
persisted
she persisted
well done thanks nice did you were you
thinking about that oh okay she
persisted well you think i'm doing
material
you're a little [ __ ] that was a little
funny
do you oh would i kill you and not be so
funny speaking of you just reminded me
we got to get new chairs i know oh you
could hear it so you just heard that and
i heard that but you were you were
sitting in my chair i know wait move
around a little bit
i don't know see i think you must bounce
a lot but you don't normally do i think
you were
not the most comfortable version of
yourself so you were
squeaking like crazy i was yeah maybe i
was moving around a lot see because when
i readjust we gotta get new chairs there
yeah or oil them or something god you
know what's funny i i remember um i
posted this thing on uh
instagram about a cartoon i remember i
don't know i was just thinking about
being younger last night drawing a lot
when i was a kid but i i remember
jumping around so much in my chair in
school i used to fidget so much you were
fidgety yeah you were probably um
maybe not probably 80 almost definitely
in need of medication
as a kid
but i think you were you were so smart
that you and charming that you were able
to
get through you know
i persisted you persisted he persists he
persisted
not to say that people who uh
you know who need that are not smart but
i think you just like
you kind of just maneuvered your way
through the system who was i just
talking to you have you heard me say
some to talk about adhd being
misdiagnosed i i was just talking about
to somebody about that they're doing
something familiar uh a guest on the
show um and i and i really think this is
my theory is that because i was just a
little old i just missed the big
uh adderall boom yeah by a couple years
ritalin adderall those when they started
dragging up i think mike around my class
yeah that they started my classmates
started to get yeah the pharmacy medical
industries somehow warmed their way
um
into
our culture on a few occasions she would
um
she turned the tables and asked you a
question whatever she did
i got nervous well yeah i was going to
say yeah correct me if i'm wrong but you
seem to panic a little bit yeah and i
understand why i mean her just her voice
when yeah it's so synonymous with
these um high-stakes interviews
we've all seen so many of these high
stakes and you know with like bashar
al-assad yeah so even when when she's
asked you something like oh what did you
think the michael j foxbow oh just the
tone of her voice it it caused a little
panic they did and then you like spewed
out all your thoughts as quickly as you
could it was like this verbal diarrhea
well you know and she and she's good at
being patient and listening to the
answer yeah and not cutting you off i
know so you just went until you were
done i just
i like [ __ ] it all out like this is all
and trying to because i also want to
sound impressive to her i think because
i i
i i'm so respectful of her you know i
really value her intellect and
um her the speed with which she gets
thoughts and the efficiency with which
she expresses herself
uh she's so eloquent i wanted to be all
those i understand and um i'm not all
those
well you can be if you're relaxed yeah
yeah yeah so so you're saying my answer
was uh it was a little uh it was fine
but i could just hear the idea behind it
i wonder if people could hear that
because i it's you're right you're right
and it was like your chair was squeaking
away
oh god but it's also a subject that i
love talking about usually and i
want i mean well how do you say it's
true how do you sum that up what would
you which michael j fox oh what do you
think i might just [ __ ] take me hours
to do that right
um and certainly and with the book i had
so many thoughts i had just listened to
that book and i had right so many right
thoughts about but she wasn't asking for
a book report she just said
that's what did you think of it that's
what it felt like i thought did you hear
yeah
can you oil chairs you know we should
just get i like spinning chairs swivel
chairs i like
the the um
the seat of the chair i love it i love
the cushion yeah
yeah but i also like the idea of swivel
chairs but maybe not for this format
because it'll help me maybe stand still
like sit still
that might help you emotionally too yeah
be more grounded mm-hmm
ah [ __ ]
was it was it i i was i think because
i'm
now i'm gonna do it because i hear the
squeak when we
use them
i might be more i know but forget this
week and now i'm thinking about my own
uh oh your answer yeah no it was fine i
know you and i and i could tell that you
were
trying to sound impressive yeah and it
was a big question and and you gave a
bit of a book report answer instead of
it's really impressive he uh
you know he's overcome so much and you
said all the things you just said like
eight times too much
i know i know exactly what you're
talking about
oh man i hope michael chief fox was
listening to that because i also want to
god it was so i i that
that book was so um
important i think for me and and it was
so it's had such an impact on me i want
to read it yeah it's really
beautiful and funny and uh not to rehash
what i told katie couric but you should
definitely read it i would listen to it
actually because he also gives a really
beautiful performance you talk about
that oh i do okay yeah
um i never realized she talked about
nodding as an interviewer and i never
realized that it make and it makes
perfect sense
that this rule exists but you're not
supposed to nod
as an interviewer because it it
it indicates that you're a green person
yes i know but i nod and when i nod i
think like 99 of my nods
are
yes i understand i'm absorbing it
exactly yeah and not
i'm agreeing with you well i i mean you
also don't talk to like ayatollah
khomeini not yet
yeah i mean maybe it's different when
like you said she's in these high-stakes
conversations conversations i mean
that's the thing she comes from that
world where it's like i'm going to
that's why that sarah palin interview is
such a good example of i'm just going to
get things out of you i'm going to
extract uh your your
belief system from you in in uh as and
you have to be deft and you have to be
conscientious of things like that of
of being in a group you know of course
indicating that you agree but here's the
thing the opposite of nodding is shaking
your head right
and i
there's not that equivalency because if
i shake my head when someone's talking
right and granted i'm not talking to
ayatollah
i'm shaking my head that means no i
don't agree with what you're saying it
doesn't normally mean i don't understand
you
whereas when i nodded someone i think it
usually means yeah i understand what
you're saying i'm thinking of like yes
people like a george plimpton being like
i'm listening exactly
but think about someone going like this
too
i would do that christian's shaking his
head i would do that if
you know somebody was saying something
really awful or oh my can you think i
was incredible
no no if they were saying like oh and i
saw
you know
i i don't know i saw him right side
something horrible
guts all over the road i'd be like
that's true no you know it'd be like
incredulous like i can't believe it like
i don't agree with that yeah like that's
no good i don't i don't i'm not
processing that in a i'm not positive
about with that that's not exist living
positively but there should be and i if
nodding is i understand the op there
should be an opposite i don't understand
and i think wouldn't that just be you'd
have to interject verbally but that's
why i want to study sign language that
guy david cohen
i posted all about david cohen the guy
who looks like david letterman with a
really impressive white beard the bald
guy who was signing for
the we saw the governor
of georgia speaking but he is
what he's so expressive in the way he
signs they all are
yes i know he happens to be he happens
more i think so really i think he
happens to be better at performing it um
do you know who i think is even better
than him oh somebody told me a guy i saw
the other day um the governor of
maryland did a press conference oh yeah
you like that guy he was amazing i
couldn't take my eyes off him oh you got
to see that my friend studied asl
american sign language in in college and
she recommended she said amber galloway
is the queen
she says she could watch her videos for
forever i used to know the alphabet oh
yeah well we can study it uh that's
actually a really good um new year's
resolution because i one of my
resolutions was to i have 10 of them one
of them was to learn something new
learning anything new yeah and i hadn't
and i hadn't uh pinpointed what i wanted
like a new skill yeah because you could
argue that like learning to cook a new
food is something new i wouldn't in my
metric that yeah okay what about yeah
that would count well learning a
language would count learning sign
language would count yeah anyway katie
couric is
so good the lightning round and by the
way i think
um maybe the first actual lightning
round we've ever had oh really yeah like
she answered all the questions so
efficiently
and quickly
in a you know speedy lightning e way
yeah
and um i i like when that round
no i like it when it often turns into
um a longer discussion i like that yeah
but there's something nice about here
are my efficient answers questions yeah
i really appreciated it yeah she's uh i
think part of it is just because she's
so bright that when i said this is the
lightning round she took it uh not
literally but um
well yeah i guess literally would that
be taking it literally no i guess
literally figurative expression i guess
so she took a figurative expression
literally yeah
i guess you could say that katie
and anyone has not made
you it let's read a letter isn't it cool
i could call her katie i mean she was uh
i noticed that you kept calling her
katie every chance you got really you're
like another question katie because i
think she's you're so proud that you
were able to call her well such a
familiar name because she seems more
like because she's such a youthful
energy too she seems like more of a
contemporary not a contemporary
intellectually i fall
not on like my level
in you know a journalistic sense uh but
just
as a as a person i it would feel weird
oh i know her also a little bit i have
like some tangential
interaction with her so it feel weird to
call it you met her before
you know what how could you not remember
well no no i this is the misleading
thing about instagram oh you met her at
that yeah through instagram like we
follow each other and we'll like but you
never did or you never um oh what am i
talking about i
no i you know i never did a show
of course i would remember that yeah i
would think so um
i would definitely remember that i but i
i have such a bad memory and also on
those morning shows it's such a
whirlwind doing them it's like you go in
and the makeup and then like oh you go
out for like five minutes and it's like
and they're all at different desks so
i mean you've met hoda i've definitely
met hoda i've i've in fact i'm yeah i've
made you're almost friends with hoda
well i made the uh i made a hoe joke
with hoda you did i did yeah yeah we
were i was talking to kathie lee and i
said i called her kath
and i said i feel like i can call you
kath now i've been i can shorten your
name and and hoda said you know hoda
made the joke she said just don't
shorten oh no maybe i made the joke i
said i i don't know if i should do that
with hoda yet
and she was like oh and they started
laughing they're fun cheeky gals i like
those too
hoda and kat ho ho and kath
maybe future guests it'd be great um
i think we should read a letter yeah
let's do it okay
anyway um
katie if you are listening this far uh
thank you and i'm sorry i'm sorry
uh okay
let's see
uh okay here we go this is a letter from
a nice simple strong name mike morgan
what a name yeah like morgan
subject salutations
this letter is long overdue but because
of my procrastination i now get to
mention how terrific the vince vaughn
episode is oh i wonder why it's long
overdue
maybe just he meant to write
maybe i should wait and
learn why it might be long overdue and
not edit editorial yeah okay sorry mike
and thank you uh justin is such a knack
for bringing out the best in guests and
seeing hearing this side of vince was
such a treat
it was a treat i loved listening to
vincent vince gushing aside the original
intent of this letter is to gush about
justin's performances brandon st randy
oh so many years ago in a movie filled
with hilarious moments none are funnier
than the scenes with brandon and i
consider it the greatest cameo of all
time thank you mike oh that's why the
subject was salutations i say that oh
yeah salutations
i'd love to hear you talk about it in
depth next time you have a zack and
miriko star on that's a good idea
brandon routh or seth rogen elizabeth
banks yep
uh but for now i want to know how many
of your lines that made it on screen
were improvised in exchange i offer a
would you rather blow
that's nice thank you both for the
terrific content each week that makes
these weird times a bit brighter and
then he's got these would you rather's
um but we have we have a deal mike so i
would say um
improvised lines were
it's probably you know probably about
half the lines i would
say
kevin smith let us do a lot of that he
would do these long takes and so
we would we would do a lot of
improvising but uh didn't you do a thing
for the end credits oh my god all the
separate scenes yeah that was all
improvised all improvised that was yeah
i'm improvised that was what was that uh
yeah so fun but and seth rogen obviously
is so good at that uh so is elizabeth so
spanx and brandon ralph was fine hey we
did a lot mike to answer your question
i'm trying to remember like i said
you listen to the show you don't have a
terrible memory but i do know the line
um
i hear this line a lot from people you
better
i'm just gonna say you better shut your
mouth or i'm gonna [ __ ] it was a line
that our friend my friend john togo
told me he overheard at a restaurant
used to work at uh a very muscular
gentleman saying that to his lover you
better shut your mouth or i'm gonna kiss
it and i just thought we always thought
it was the funniest thing to be that
aggressive and flirtatious at the same
time
so kevin smith uh liked it left it in
the movie but the original line was poo
punchers i was in poo punchers
one through four
and then six through eight don't ask me
about it was poo punchers kevin smith
yeah that was kevin smith
uh you know i've noticed on instagram
occasionally people have said that i
sound like your character in that movie
have you ever really you've seen that no
i've seen it maybe 10 times what yeah
really yeah
i i had a very bad
flu i think when i was doing that very
bad cold
and and i so my voice was kind of
naturally lower and sort of nasally okay
back to the letter would you rather know
everything everyone said about you
behind your back or have everyone know
everything you've said about them behind
their back
that is good that's a good one um
oh wow you know what uh
[ __ ] that is good you know what's so
funny we encountered this version of
this last night i was talking to a
friend on the phone
and um
i we hung up
or we were supposed to hang up and i i
didn't hang up yet and i realized he
hadn't hung up his phone
and there was just all these kind of
ambient noises of him getting out of his
car and like he was about to go inside
he was going home and i was um
so curious what he curious and kind of
scared there was like a voyeuristic
feeling that i had about what he might
say about having just talked to me
and i hung up before i could hear
anything yeah who was that person uh
friend
yeah
um
yeah so jerry i hung you had not hung up
the phone but uh and i encouraged you to
hang out to hang out yeah yeah
yes well here's one of the reasons the
main reason i think i
didn't right away was because one of the
funniest things i've ever heard in my
life was the result of not having hung
up the phone when jerry hadn't hung up
the phone and was when he was going
through a drive-through
at taco bell and i got to hear him order
that taco bell drive-through
i know this doesn't sound funny but to
this day it's it will forever it's i
think it'll forever be one of the
funniest things i've ever heard he said
um there was like a long pause and then
he just said i heard somebody say yes
can i help you it was on my voicemail it
was on yours bad memory yeah and and
jerry just said uh
yes i'd like three
three cheesy bean and rice burritos and
thread what oh she's got speed no no no
no no no no no
he's gonna be he's gonna want to cut
he'll be yeah he'll be mad okay um and a
large diet pepsi yeah large diet pepsi
we should try to play it as the have we
played that
would you rather know everything
everyone has said about you behind your
back or have everyone know everything
you've said about them behind their back
uh
what do you think um i have an answer i
would say uh
god everything
i guess i'd rather hear everything
everyone said about me me too and i say
that because it's something i'm not
proud of yeah i
sometimes have an instinct
to be
a little gossipy yeah and um and i've
said something and i'm not proud and
that's something i want to change about
myself yeah and i think i've gotten
better you yeah you have but um you know
i've had instincts to be to talk about
people behind their body you both have
to want to talk about people left behind
their backs
i know and i know like it would be
obviously very scary to have to hear it
it'd be awful and
yeah it would be hard but you know what
that's kind of i'd rather do that it's
almost like it's literally your penance
for having talked [ __ ] about people and
it's almost like it's the same question
of would you rather
break up with someone or be broken up
and i would all be broken up with broken
up me too because it's gonna hurt but
i i'd much rather deal with the hurt
that was coming my way yeah than to have
to deal with
you know someone else's hurt and to deal
with the
uh we're guilty of conscience
of having hurt someone yeah i agree
we're wired that way whatever that means
i don't i don't think it necessarily
means we're good people
or they're not good yeah i think we're
just like just good people i no it's
just i if anything it makes us maybe
more uh
narcissistic maybe more self-serving i
don't know if you'd say that
i don't know i'd like to i'm a bit of a
masochist so
yeah i would want to hear also i think
hearing what people really think of you
it might help you um
clarify your relationship yeah it'd be
well said and yeah maybe clean house a
little bit yeah
yeah or that'd be a tough day though to
get those transcripts maybe
it'd be really hard to go through that
you would need
i mean i don't want to encourage
drinking but i think just me personally
i would have to
i would have to be a little i'd have to
have something i would say that would
make it so much worse what do you think
yeah oh yeah
you know
what would you do here's a take
it might in a weird way be worse if you
got all these transcripts of people
talking about you
and there was like nothing in them
oh like you don't have something like no
one's thoughts about you oh yeah
no one cares
no but i'm thinking of people in your
life that i'm
i'm
they definitely talk they do i'm saying
in theory yeah i know i i don't think
this would happen just like that it's
all blank in theory it's like no no
one's ever said anything about you yes
yeah or it's just like oh i feel like
they uh might like uh
rye bread
you know like i'm really innocuous to me
i would like that because then you get
both ends you get
to know that people care enough about
you
talking about you and it's not bad see
yeah but it would never i mean best case
scenario people are just nice about it
it's all just positive stuff he's like
every time i leave hanging out with him
i just want more you know stuff like
that
but that's not what people do i mean
it's not what i do it's which is why i i
think you too it which is why we're
we're choosing that option because the
things i've said things about people
um that i'm not i'm not proud of and i
and a lot of things that i i no longer
with like some real soul-searching don't
probably don't really feel i would say
most of the stuff i've said i could back
up if if forced to and i could defend
but i still wouldn't right you don't
just talk [ __ ] to like no exactly but i
still wouldn't want to have to be in the
position to do that and to maybe hurt
someone's feelings i would i would not i
would hate that yes and and what if it's
somebody that you've had a change in
your relationship what if it's like your
relationship has evolved and
you have gotten to know them better and
you don't feel that way you don't feel
that way yeah well then do you just say
that i guess so i guess it's
it's a great question though it really
is mike and um
thank you my god thank you better shut
your mouth i thank you mike for that you
know i've been doing a lot of that
character on cameo uh and it's really
fun because it's not it's a pretty easy
thing for me to slip into it's not like
um
you know some character that i have to
somebody asked me to do a scene from
tusk the other day on that on that app
they said can you just do this see that
was one of the most challenging not to
sound pretentious but it was such a
difficult thing to do at the time and i
needed i relied heavily on my scene
partner in the makeup and all the crew
and other and uh
and i was just like
i was like the thought of just launching
into that i need i need to prepare but
uh brandon st randy is a fun one because
that comes very easy oh my god please
anyway um
yeah thank you thank you brandon thank
you mike and thank you to our
distinguished
guest katie
couric part of me hopes she's listening
part of me hope she's not
uh but what more what's the i hope she
is yeah yeah yeah um but i'm more
importantly than that i'm glad all of
you are listening and if you would like
to write in our email address is life is
short at wondery.com
so thank you and i'm gonna sign off uh
in a way that i'm gonna try not to be
self-conscious about katie listening to
me signing off because already it's
disappointing
she would do it much better she would do
something like this
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you've been listening to life is short
i'm your host justin long life short is
hosted by me
[Music]
audio engineer is sergio enriquez and
two executive producers get their hands
on this one one being marshall louie and
fernan lopez for quandary
[Music]
question is blondes
or brunettes
which do you prefer
in parentheses
opposite sex
she's like
she's like baiting me
it's too dangerous you can't answer that
why not
for me i don't care it's all about a
woman's soul
wait hair on her head or
oh stop
you